weirdly doubt during lockdown you've
featured in an awful lot of means I'm
sure you know this I'm sure you've
you've seen them this one became popular
here when the government announced that
they were planning to reopen the
school's when seven asked if I'll
continue to home-school after the
lockdown god no God please no no no and
then this one it sort of was after our
prime minister here Boris was trying to
explain the new rules in easing of
lockdown and it wasn't Toby clear and
somebody noticed the resemblance to this
Bruce Almighty was kind of your thing
wasn't it they they well they continued
that was basically the first time I was
ever in a movie and the part they cut
out is when Jim Carrey makes my nose
start to bleed profusely which they
thought to mean of him to do as a
character and then my head burst into
flames they had a they had a like a gas
line it wasn't even a special effect
like a digital effect it was a real live
practical effect they ran a gas line up
like down my back and they put a coil on
top of my head and they actually and
they like put gel on my head so it
wouldn't burn and they ignited this
enormous and it had to be like a four
foot flame that I said I'm sure it's in
some DVD extra somewhere yes it is we
found it here's a screen grab I mean
that is your actual head on fire that
must be terrifying oh yes sure that was
the most terrifying thing ever because
you could hear them venting the gas line
before it happened it kind of went
because and then I knew who's gonna go
full full-blown torch and I could see
that the crew in front of me they all
lit up because the
was so bright terrifying yeah it's
really it's really hard to relax and do
improv when a gas hissing oh well as
you're in my in my first movie what was
I gonna say I'm not gonna do it of
course sure light me on fire sounds
terrific
[Music]